(mellow electronic music)
- Thanks.
- I wanna see.
- Don't look at that.
- Holy shit!
- [Man] Yeah, I had dreads in college.
- You're 24!
- [Man] How old are you?
- Oh, I'm 34.
I'm 10 years older than you.
- Hot.
- It's not hot.
- Yes, it is, yeah it's great.
- No, you lack experience.
- [Man] We'll see.
- We will not see.
Martini!
Yeah, maybe just one drink.
- Perfect, we've got everything.
What do you want?
- [Woman] A Scotch?
- We don't have that, but
we have flavored Vodka.
- [Woman] That's disgusting.
- [Roommate] Ooh!
Not so close.
- Oh, you're having a party?
- No, these are my roommates.
- [Group] Yeah!
Woo!
- Stressful.
- Bathroom is right there.
- Thank you.
This is a portal to hell.
Nope.
Can you put your phone away?
Work was garbage today, can you just
please put that--
- Sure babe.
- Thank you.
- What can I do
to cheer you up?
- Nothing, can we just.
Let's just drink wine and watch TV.
- Or
boom.
- I don't do video games.
No, no, no, no!
- Babe, it's like three in the morning.
No!
Yeah, go to bed.
Slow down.
- [Man] Oh, sorry.
- [Woman] Even slower.
- [Man] Okay.
- Slower than you can possibly imagine.
Okay, you can look.
- Alright.
What is it?
- [Woman] I cleaned your bathroom.
- Oh!
Thank you.
- Do you love it?
- Oh, yeah!
I love it.
- Good, yeah.
- How's this?
- Good.
- Cool.
- Okay, slow down, slow down.
- [Man] Sorry.
- That's okay.
I didn't really wanna cum anyway.
- Babe, are we hanging or chilling?
- I don't understand the question.
- Like, are we exclusive, or like?
- Yeah, you're my boyfriend.
- No, I knew that.
You're my girlfriend.
I've had a girlfriend before.
Not a big deal.
I wanna get on top.
- Oh, no, no, no, stay down.
I have a system.
(funky pop music)